l'arbitrage une passion pour inès
tarawih la jeunes taekwondoïstes de 15
ans licencié au club de trappes a décidé
d'endosser ce costume en 2016
aujourd'hui la sportive arbitres sur une
compétition interdépartemental parce que
j'aime bien arbitré car arbitrer
ça donne du coup une certaine
indépendance ce combat
du coup je suis aussi combattante du
coup l'effet d'arbitré ça permet du coup
d'avoir la double casquette je trouve ça
du coup ainsi intéressante
pour s'améliorer inès reçoit
régulièrement des conseils d'arbitré
plus expérimentés présents autour des
combats pendant les compétitions
le pas est ce tu es l'un peut qu au
cours des 20 décembre à pau
sinon c'est bien tu t'es bien déplacé
pas bien vu des choses ce que j'apprécie
énormément chez elle c'est son sérieux
sa présence elle écoute les conseils à
des appliques sa qualité première c'est
très clairement son impartialité
même si elle doit arbitrer comme son
club je sais que est fera aucune
différence entre les combattants
l'arbitrage un axe fort pour le
développement de la discipline
aujourd'hui comme inès une vingtaine de
jeunes sont présents pour arbitrer la
compétition c'est extrêmement important
pour notre sport d'avoir des jeunes qui
s'impliquent dans l'arbitrage
et c'est aussi important pour eux parce
qu'en tant que combattant de connaître
les règles et les ficelles d'arbitrage
c'est ce qui va leur permettre
d'améliorer encore leurs capacités dans
les combats inès espère maintenant
passer son diplôme jeune arbitre
national et pourquoi pas rêver encore
plus grand et devenir arbitre
international